[Music]
and our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us in the small surf town of
Seal Beach in Southern California donuts
are suddenly selling fast
that's because customers of this
mom-and-pop shop made it their mission
to help the owners in their time of need
John Blackstone went to donut City early
one morning to see how people are coming
from all over to pay it forward seven
days a week
John Chan arrives a little after 4:00 in
the morning to open his doughnut shop in
Seal Beach California the first
customers arrived by 4:30 these days you
have to get there early because the
doughnuts are likely to be sold out
before dawn take care of the staff today
at my kids elementary school since 1990
john chan has been behind the counter
with his wife Stella by his side how is
she doing
John's wife of more than 30 years is now
recovering from a brain aneurism her
sister stepped in to help out but
customers immediately missed Stella
she's smiling and full of life always in
a great mood just as hi how are you good
morning because of their affection for
the man who makes the confections the
community wanted to help as word spread
about Stella people said oh we'll give
you some money we'll open a GoFundMe
page we'll give you some money
oh no if you don't want it you have you
couldn't not buy I can make my life
right now
I miss Alice you couldn't nothing you
didn't want people to just give you no
no no I'm not used we wanted to offer
John some money but he's a proud man and
didn't want to take it so I said let's
just come here buy his inventory out
every morning early so he can get home
and be with his wife and help command
her back to full health
one person shared Chan's story on social
media suggesting the community could
help out and bring doughnuts to work
church school because as soon as the
doughnuts are sold out
could leave and spend more time with his
wife suddenly Donuts were selling by the
dozens and dozens give me a four dozen
you heard about this from your daughter
my daughter and her husband are
stationed in Hawaii they're military and
she got ahold of us and said we needed
to come down and support this family
maybe but I don't mind I like that John
and Stella are refugees from Cambodia
they became part of the fabric of this
community selling doughnuts to
generation after generation yeah they're
national treasures here at Seal Beach 28
years right here yeah they're great
people and that is why morning after
morning as the Sun comes up the donuts
are disappearing thank you every day
I've just a second say thank you very
much for neighbor or community they all
happy me so much by 6:45 just more than
two hours after Chan open okay nearly
everything is gone
but the holes the whole path of doing it
yes is there anything left for you to
order I ordered the second pan there
were two pounds when we took them off in
this little shop by the sea
the only thing sweeter than the donuts
is the outpouring of affection for the
man behind the counter I just want to
say thank you for CBS this morning John
Blackstone Seal Beach California we
needed that we needed a reminder that
there is humanity in this country and
that people really want to do good and
do well and help others kindness - never
ever ever goes out of stone not for
nothing you could tell those donuts look
good look at those he does a good job in
refugees as national treasures and
someone who does not want a handout he
didn't want money he's had his product
word all for itself and the community
helped I'm biased but I'm a friend of
refugees this one checks all the box
right you've got great food great hearts
in the community and people coming in
for
thousands of miles away anybody with a
heart can Tobias when you look at a
street should be biased when you look at
story like that thank you John
Blackstone yeah all done thank you is to
eat donuts yeah